so we got something we're going to
reveal today for the first time we're
going to show some footage today from
rudy giuliani
from mafia states of america on what was
said about mario cuomo
and you reached out to the cuomo camp to
see if andrew cuomo had anything to say
about that multiple times they did not
want to respond it turns out he had some
other things to deal with yeah
extracurricular activities but you know
we won't go there so michael first of
all why don't we uh go and talk about
the sit down with you and sami okay
we talked about this for a while you
know it was gonna happen it wasn't gonna
happen mike sammy didn't want to do it
you didn't want to do it and then you
guys spoke and it's like let's see if we
can do it and then we had a few calls
together
uh what got you to a point to finally
want to do this i'm sure millions of
people have been asking about when is
this going to happen but what made you
say you know what let's do this sit down
you know
first of all a lot of people wanted it
it seemed you know i would get it for
some reason it was even before the
thought was even you know
moving around to to sit with him people
are saying you know what you're feeling
about sammy do you ever going to sit
down with him was he the real deal and
what do you think about the murder i
mean i i got so many sammy questions so
you know i was just i was sitting my
with my wife and i said you know maybe
i'll talk to sammy and we'll see if we
can put this together and that's that's
really how it happened and then when we
did it you guys you you brought your
camp yeah you brought his camp
you guys were in two different
you know properties we had you on this
side we had semi on this side and the
whole thing starts how do you think it
went i mean first of all we have how
many hours of footage we have uh
including the drone footage we've got 26
hours 26 hours of footage of which let's
be honest seventy percent is sam i would
say 24 hours with sammy talking
but but how did you think it went
you know i mean look i'm glad it
happened you know you know there's so
much nonsense going on in the internet
right now i mean guys are just coming
out of the woodwork you know a lot of
them i never even heard of before but
um look there was a uh
sammy and i were really a part of that
life on the level that we were on he was
the underboss i was a couple at that
time
and even though things you know sammy
did what he did i did what i did there's
still a certain amount of respect there
it's just you just feel it inside you
know even though we both are out of the
life he disagrees on that for some
reason he still thinks he's causing
austria i said you want to walk down the
streets of brooklyn with me and let's
see how cousin austria are but
but um why what would happen if you walk
down the streets of brooklyn well i'll
leave that up to you tomorrow
strike that question for this
some guy from iowa named todd with neck
tattoos who tried to serve him milk
latte okay but i can't explain it you
know there's still
speaking to him there's a certain amount
of respect that i feel you know and i
think he felt the same for me so that
came out you know and and these
sit-downs
you know it's amazing patrick you can be
away from the life for me now what 20
some odd years
but sometimes i'll get off a plane in
new york and the feeling comes right
back like it's like i never left
and when i sat down with sammy i almost
felt the same way we're at a sit down
and there's a level of respect that you
have for one another regardless of what
either one of us did and i think it came
out during that i mean he got a little
testy we both got a little testy at some
point and uh you know i had to remind
him he's not the underboss anymore you
know just calm down and and he said some
things to me and we both said some
things you know at different times about
each other that weren't you know very
nice
but i think uh all in all it went pretty
well yeah i mean i i showed obviously
there's a lot of different uh uh
sections to the interview but it was a
part when i showed a clip with you and
mike tyson
where i i asked sammy i said sammy i
want to show you video with what michael
said about you with on mike tyson just
to see what reaction would be and it was
a clip of you
saying uh sammy had what was it napoleon
syndrome right yeah
on his worst day
gotti on his worst day was better than
sammy on his best day
and how much has that changed from that
comment being made on tyson to now after
having that two days two and a half days
we spend with sammy well you gotta
understand something you know prior to
me sitting down with sammy i spent a lot
of time with my dad
and the talk about sammy you got to be
honest was not good you know from
especially guys like my father who would
never say a word about anybody to the
car he'd rather die you know 100 deaths
and say a word about anybody so to guys
like my father sammy was a bad guy you
know
why though why
because what he did with john i mean you
know look testified against gotti
testified against a whole bunch of guys
so the word on the street with respect
to that was no good with sammy and
especially from my dad
and he didn't know sammy you know he
never met him but
so he didn't have a personal
relationship with him in any way but
what he did you know on the street was
no good
so
gotti look gotti was not an easy guy to
get along with he was a narcissistic
type of guy i got along with him when i
had to i had a couple of disputes with
him
um
but he was a stand-up guy at the end of
the day i mean he went to jail he didn't
talk about anybody and that was it and
on the street that matters
that matters so
that's why i made that comment
you know it strictly pertained to that
but look i got to know sammy now it's a
different story and he had his reasons
for doing that i'm not going to judge it
anymore
and um you know he's trying to turn his
life around i see how he is with his
family he's great
so you know who am i to judge you know
look
we were all on the street we all did the
things that we did maybe some guy did a
little bit more than another guy but
we're all guilty of that
and you know i've come to that you know
conclusion and realization so i don't
want to talk about anybody uh sammy and
i are different we have a different you
know way of looking at all of this and i
think it came out you know in the city
oh yeah yeah yeah michael
prior to the sit down that you did with
patrick and gerard and obviously with
sammy how many times had you met sammy
in person how many times have you met
gotti in person prior to the sit down
well i met gotti several more times than
sammy you know back in the day um
i we met sammy one time that's it that
was it so this was your second time
meeting sammy in your entire life sammy
was sammy uh uh
straight up feared like he would sit
there was he a dialogue guy or was he a
guy that would just sit there focus on
you and watch every move and extremely
paranoid skeptical what was uh sammy
known for back in the days not today
yeah sammy's got a sense of humor he's
very charming yeah absolutely great and
great storyteller very oh yeah he's
engaging to be around there's no doubt
about it i mean i enjoyed the time we
spent we spent several hours together i
went out to hours i want to see him we
spent several hours together
um
you know look
he had a reputation on the street no
doubt about it and we heard things about
him again it wasn't my personal involved
with the involvement with him
but uh i don't want to get into all of
that now because we do get into it when
we sit down i think that's fair so let's
talk about
you brought up your dad sonny
uh we you and i met with them multiple
times we went to new york and we're
trying to do something with them
and one time we had the whole crew there
we were at the uh
the not hospital i don't know what you
would call that it was the veterans
hospital veterans hospital we were at
and
talking to him and so i'm driving him in
the car and we're going to this italian
restaurant i don't know if you remember
what the name of the italian restaurant
was yeah so we go to this italian
restaurant
the lady is really nice who owns the
shop she's taking care of us being good
to us and every time i ask your dad a
question hey sonny what what do you what
was it like what was lucky like
fantastic guy
he's a great guy great family guy
sunny
lucky's got a history great guy was
always respectful how about meyer they
said he was a billionaire what do you
think was he that kind of a guy he had
money i have no i have no idea but great
guy phenomenal guy so i say how about
ben siegel how was ben another great guy
so i said sammy so all the movies are
like sunny all the movies are lying
these are great people that i dealt with
i said sunny why don't we do the
interview
so you tell the world who you were
rather than
the world telling everybody who you were
i don't want to do that
why don't you want to do that so one
time i went there you weren't there your
sister was there
they were upset you know she was upset
she was like you know because you know i
think i like two or three meetings mario
was there mario pulls up his dad looks
at mario's like
who are you
mari says and by the way at 101 when we
first met him presents like a man you've
never met in one he died at 103. just so
you know that so that's why you look so
good at 70. you're going to go to 100
easy adam his presence
unreal at 101 so he goes like this to
mario who are you
mario says
i'm i'm just i'm here with patrick he
says you rat
martial 101 years old he sees asking
mario's tony francis so mario's like no
no no i'm not a rat i'm not a rat he
says you sure he says yeah he says you
know 95 of men out there are rants says
you're gonna rat on this guy he's
telling this to mario right on you yeah
so at this point first i mean at this
point it's getting very uncomfortable
mario's getting uncomfortable and
mario's already changed his pants
[Laughter]
and then mario's like no not
sunny he's a great guy he says
okay linda
linda come fix my hair come here linda
grab the cone so the nurse comes and she
starts fixing and saying why are you
doing it that way go the other way you
know how i like it you can tell man's
presence
on how sonny was you know i'm gonna be
honest with you i knew i was fortunate
to meet a lot of guys at that time you
know from chin to fat tony to castellano
gaudio it was nobody like my dad
i mean it and i'm not
you know i'm trying to be as objective
as i possibly can there was really
nobody like him what was your dad like
when he was you know doing his you know
back in the day he had and that's why he
became such a major target i mean what
nobody really understands i mean if
you're around that time you knew my dad
was the john gotti of his day before
they had you know social media and all
this kind of stuff he was a john gotti
he became such a target of law
enforcement i mean look he's indicted
four times in the 60s
media like you wouldn't believe front
page all the time and he was the guy
and it was his presence you know he just
had a presence about him back then he
walked into a room you knew
you know he was there that was it all
the focus went on him you go to the
corporate i mean i was with my dad i'll
never forget we were in the copacabana
um i forget who was playing i think was
jimmy roselli it was jimmy roselli and
joe columbo came in at that time and my
father had to tell
the waiters to take care of joe colombo
because everybody was catering to my
father you know catering don't know joe
columbus he was the boss and and i saw
him do that a couple of times where all
the attention always went to him and
somebody else came in the room he said
hey take care of that you know who he is
you know be respectful
um he just commanded that kind of
presence if you could summarize your
father in you know three major words is
there any words that come to mind you
know charismatic um powerful you know i
mean those two words you know and and
loving i mean as a father he was
terrific
never missed a baseball game of mine
wanted me to go to college
you know just a good husband at that
time to my mom i mean he was just in in
the house he was great he loved him what
year 19 years he was born in 17 19. he
was born in naples my dad was born my
grandfather came here and yeah my
grandfather came here several years
earlier but he would go back by boat
every year to naples
and my father was born on a boat trip he
was one of 19 kids by the way one of 19
19 kids no facebook no youtube yeah
nothing else to do
you're saying there was no facebook in
1919 that was one of the crazy parts
about the uh the interview frankly man
was watching two men actually sit there
have a conversation not look at their
phone for 16 straight hours
and that's that's the thing after being
with my dad and he he taught me a lot he
taught me how to navigate that life
i was never in awe of anybody else i
respected them no doubt but i never
you know gotti to me was all right you
know he's
he tries to be have that big presence my
father didn't have to try
he just was who he was that was it big
difference oh yeah there's nobody you
were in of so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]